and that'll load the bases so a rough
first inning
to start for mazda let's see if you can
keep the yankees off the board here's
george
and the 3-2
fly ball
right field puello makes a catch tagging
is lemay here's the throw it's cut off
lemay scores
and as the sac fly for rochelle and it's
one nothing angles it takes so long to
get rid of the ball i mean is as strong
as his arm is just look at the extra
time here it's just not a quick release
and that extra hop and that's just an
extra step which allows the runner to
get in there so here's clint
frazier one is lined in the left center
field it's a base hit
chavis fields
scoring is judge
boyd stops at second it's an rbi single
for fraser and it's two nothing else
well is just causing too much trouble
for himself to pitch against a hot
lineup and give this many opportunities
to score runs you're going to give up
some the red thunder drives it into left
center field the veteran lefty j happ
be his eighth start on the year and you
see his numbers have rounded out nicely
he's been on a good little run here you
see only 13 walks
in those 36 in the third innings and
over his last five starts
he's got a 2.45 era
swing and a miss chased the pitch out of
the zone one away and the way the
playoffs are laid out this year j-hat
and jordan montgomery become very
important parts of the puzzle there are
no days off
as devers looks at a call third strike
the pitch to bradley is cut out of
missed he strikes out and that is
strikeout number three for hap two down
he'll be a 2-2
to the right-hand hitting arroyo and hat
deals struck him out swinging high
fastball away hitting the spots moving
the basketball around here is higashioka
ground ball and off the glove of the
diving arroyo and it trickles into right
field frazier is going to score
talkman moves to third
higashiyoka with an rbi single and it's
three nothing yanks he has to score
another run and move another runner in
the scoring position over to third base
rather yeah first and third
and let's see what
wade does hit shortly right to short
there's one
and he throws it away
he throws it away allowing talkman to
score and giving the yankees a four
nothing lead taking it to second himself
and weight is so fast that was probably
not the best thing to do yeah this ball
hit plenty hard enough for an easy
double play but again sometimes the
shifts make it very hard for the second
baseman to get there
the pitch to avoid
hit shortly and pass the diving devers
and that's going to go into the corner
gardner is heading to third they're
waving him home here he comes and he
will score
so he scores from first on a single by
voight
rare that you see that it's five nothing
yankees and the bench is asking are you
okay and he said no i'm fine
because why wouldn't he be at second now
frazier hits one deep to right field
parallel back track wall see ya
great power the other way by clint
frazier and he hits a two-run home run
to make it seven-nothing yankees
boy i'll tell you what this isn't a
cheap one when you go opposite field and
fenway as a right-handed hitter fraser
has done everything the yankees could
dream about the half will deal one two
and the bits cut out of miss the high
fastball in
tied him up great pitch
here's the 2-2
strike three fastball inside corner
if i had to say one reason
why happ is having such a great night
he's able to put the ball exactly where
he wants to so here's the 3-2 plucky
leads off second with two out bottom of
the seventh the yanks have a seven
nothing lead
and hap
will deal three two struck him out
swinging fastball in mid in
very good pitch strikeout number seven
well here is reinhard hitting caesar
cuello with runners at first and third
and no one out
pitch cut on a miss playoff strikes out
and there's one away it'll be a 2-2 to
arrows runners at first and third one
man out here in the bottom of the eighth
inning and
hat ready to deal
struck him out swinging
that is strikeout number nine for half
and if he said well why because he's
locating his fastball pitch to plawecky
ground ball of third
there's one
there's the ball game as the yankees win
eight nothing they have won 10
straight
games and now they are 31 and 21 on the
season and
if the mariners lose tonight's game the
yankees will have clinched a playoff
spot